but I think I honestly think like women
have subtle misandry that we just don't
see every day and I you know I'm not
even going to say I've never said
anything like anything like that you
know like we hear like men are trash men
are the problem but if a guy goes on
social media and says women are
they're they're looked down upon even if
that's more true when you think about it
because women 100 years ago only 15
admitted to having pre-marital sex yeah
to now where what percent of women are
virgins on their wedding night so if you
look at the difference in women like
women are that's kind of just a fact in
general right but men are ashamed for
saying that but women can say men are
trash men are the problem men are this
men are that